وفي اخر التطورات في قطاع غزه افاد مراسل
الجزيره بسقوط عشرات الشهداء والجرحى في
قصف اسرائيلي استهدف منازل في شارع غزه
القديم في جباليه شمالي القطاع اضافه الى
شهداء وجرحى في منزل في منطقه السدره بحي
الدرج في غزه كما اكد مراسلنا تعرض دير
البلح ومخيم المغازي في وسط قطاع غزه لقصف
مدفعي اسرائيلي وكذلك مخيم النصيرات حيث
سقط شهداء وجرحى في غاره
اسرائيليه معنا من خان يونس مراسل الجزيره
وائل الدحدوح وائل اذا ما اطلعت انا اذا
على
التفاصيل التفاصيل دائما مع الاسف هي في
نتائج دمويه نظرا لاستمرار الغارات الجويه
لا سما في مناطق شمال قطاع غزه تحديدا في
بلده جباليا التي شهدت هذا اليوم الهجوم
الجوي الرابع الاكثر دموي من بين هذه
الغارات الاسرائيليه وبالتالي هذا
الاستهداف جاء لمربع سكني في جباليا البلد
وبالتحديد شارع غزه القديم كما يسمى الامر
الذي ادى الى انتشال اكثر من 30 شهيد حتى
الان والاعلان عن 100 كمف قود تحت ركام
هذه المنازل
ومعلوم عثمان بان هذه المناطق المراكز
السكنيه المتواجده سواء في الشمال او في
مدينه غزه او في الوسطى او في جنوب قطاع
غزه هي اصبحت مناطق مناطق لتكدس هذه
المواطنين من الذين لجوا من كامل المناطق
المحيطه المدمره الى هذه المراكز المتبقيه
في وسط هذه المدن والبلدات الفلسطينيه
ولذلك الغارات الاسرائيليه عندما تستهدف
بهذه الضراوه لمربعات سكنيه ومنازل سكنيه
عاده ما تكون هذه المنازل تحتوي على اعداد
كبيره من المواطنين ولذلك مثل هذه الغاره
هناك اعداد كبيره من الشهداء والجرحى اكثر
من 30 شهيد تم انتشالهم حتى الان وعشرات
اكثر من 100 اعلنوا عنهم كمف قود تحت ركام
هذه المنازل وهذا يعكس الاعداد الكبيره من
الشهداء والجرحى الذين سقطوا في هذه
الغاره لوحدها في حين عشرات الشهداء
والجرحى سقطوا في الاستهدافات التي سبقت
هذا الاستهداف في منطقه جباليا البلد
لوحدها اسوه بمناطق مخيم جباليا وعدد من
مناطق الشمال ايضا في بيت لاهي على سبيل
المثال مرورا بمدينه غزه التي يصنفها جيش
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي كمنط شمال قطاع غزه
ايضا هناك استهداف في منطقه الشجاعيه واخر
في منطقه الزيتون لكن واضح عثمان بان قوات
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي خلال الايام القليله
الماضيه ركزت استه هدافها على مناطق
الصحابه حي الدرج واجزاء من حي التفاح
واجزاء من حي الرمال باعتبارها المنطقه
التي اصبحت
ملاذا فقط اريد ان انوه ان هذه الصور هي
لمخيم النصيرات حيث سقط مصابون
وشهداء في هذا المكان واكيد انت يعني تعلم
عن
ذلك هذا صحيح كنا سناتي عن الحديث عنه هذه
الصور بالتاكيد تشير الى واحد من
الاستهدافات التي تعرضت لها ايضا منطقه
النصيرات
كمنط تحتويها منطقه وسط قطاع غزه هذه
المنطقه تعرضت صباحا الى عده استهدافات
جويه ولكن ايضا الى قصف مدفعي كبير قبل
قليل كان هناك استهدافات لاحد المنازل في
مخيم النصيرات وسط قطاع غزه الامر الذي
الذي ادى الى تدمير المنزل وانتشال عشره
شهداء على الاقل و ووقوع اعداد كبيره من
الجرحى وما زالت الاعمال في البحث عن جرحى
او عن شهداء تحت الركام ما تزال مستمره
ولكن دائما هناك صعوبات كبيره في عمليه
الانتشال خصوصا خلال ساعات الليل وخصوصا
عندما تكون الغارات مستمره والقصف المدفعي
وهو الاخطر مستمر على مثل هذه المناط
الامر الذي يحول دائما امام امام انجاز
هذه الطواقم طواقم الدفاع المدني والاسعاف
الى اتمام مهمتها على اكمل وجه ولذلك عاده
ما يؤجل اعمالهم الى ساعات الصباح لان
الوقت يكون صعب والامكانيات متواضعه جدا
بل متهالكه الى حد كبير ولذلك تؤجل الى
ساعات الصباح على ايه حال كما قلنا هذا
ليس الاستهداف الاول في مخيم النصيرات
سبقه استهدافات وادت الى وقوع شهداء وجرحى
وايضا مدينه او مخيم دير البلح ايضا
المجاور
للنصيحه لعده استهدافات جويه ومدفعيه ادت
الى سقوط شهداء وجرحى وهو الحال الذي عليه
منطقه خانيونس ايضا
ورفح شهداء وجرحى وصورتك انت شخصيا يعني
تدل على ذلك حماك الله شكرا لك وائل نعود
نقول نعود
اليك لاحقا ونذهب الى جباليه الى مراسل
الجزيره انس
الشريف انس ما هي المعلومات التي